[Music]
hello everyone this is gm josh frida
and today i'll be doing the first ever
edition of prepare like a pro
which is pointed out to me it is the
acronym for it is plap which i think is
kind of hilarious
so we can call it plop but okay prepare
like a pro
and i wanted to show
a game and this was between daniel
duvall and vincent kamer in the grand
prix series going on
where
dubois showed really excellent prep and
won a game i don't want to say solely
off of prep because probably he had to
make some moves but ultimately
preparation gave him a great position
and
i wanted to kind of take apart
everything that goes into the prep so
usually i have a tendency to go into
detail too much so i kind of hold back a
little bit
but because this game doesn't have too
much post opening content
i want to really focus on all the ins
and outs of what would go into this kind
of preparation for a gm
so i would say that uh before i even go
further
i want to remark that for every player
and every level of player that you face
the level of preparation you need to
know is different so if you're just
starting
a
if you're just starting as a chess
player if you're say you know under 1000
or you're just beginning chess
preparation is not that important in
that mostly you just have to know to get
your pieces out control the center
that's like number one right and i would
say that even when you become more
advanced you want to
still keep an eye on those
rules and make sure you're following
general rules or if you
don't follow them
you have to
have a good reason
and then i would say you get to levels
between
say you start to hit 1200 1400 1600 you
start to have openings and have an
opening repertoire or start to build one
so it means that you can play
different
you you kind of know the starting series
of opening moves you might know a basic
plan but probably not much beyond that
and then you get to expert level players
who have a whole repertoire usually and
sometimes they can play more than one
thing
it depends on the type of player
they usually have stuff kind of mapped
out some players play more offbeat
openings some players play all main
lines most players fall in between
and
that's all well and good but i would
still say that like really deep
preparation just does not come into play
until you get to like the very highest
of levels
so i mean okay when you start to get the
strong masters international masters
grand masters preparation plays more of
a role but even then it's usually
maybe it gives you a slight advantage if
you're white maybe you equalize easily
as you're black maybe you get the type
of position you like and it's not even
doesn't even have to be
objectively wonderful it's just a type
of position that you like
but
for this i'm not actually going to go
over any of that
i mostly want to focus on what
preparation can look like at the very
highest level
and all the various details that go into
it so rather than again just show what
was played i want to show all the
intricate details so
i'm going to show at least what i know
i'm not by any means an expert in the
opening that was played but i can show
you what i know
and what i research and have you guys
follow along
so just so you guys know i will be
checking the youtube chat so when i ask
questions feel free to give answers i
always like when people participate and
ask questions or give moves
but i really like it when people have
not just a move but an idea or a series
of moves
so without further ado let's get started
so dubai plays e4 he can play of course
many things uh hey davina
uh and i would say that
um
like most players
you kind of stick to a more or less main
repertoire and maybe play a few things
top players often play everything under
the sun and they partially do it
just so that they don't get prepared
against
but i would say that you know almost
everyone has at least home territory
so
i would say that lubov is a bit more of
an e4 player i believe
uh and kamer plays again more than a
fair collection of things but he does
play the caro khan quite a bit
so this would be an opening that was
sort of expected by duboff
so
we're all here for the bad ideas
e5 is a good move yes i agree harsh
but he plays carol khan and we get an
advanced carol
so just to cover the caro just starting
off
so i would say that to prepare deeply
you first need to learn how to prepare
in a shallow way
and of course by shallow i don't mean
the typical definition i mean
the first few moves you have to know
what's going on so basically white
builds a pawn center and black attacks
it with c6 d5
it sounds simple but
knowing the ins and outs of why you do
this is actually important
so
the
the advantage to this is that this
bishop is still open so in a french
defense you're trying to fight for the
light squares with your pawns if you
play here you're fighting for the dark
squares your opponent fights for the
light squares
and that's a completely different ball
game
the french defense which is probably the
closest opening to the caro khan
looks very similar
but there are certain there are
advantages of disadvantage this move
keeps this bishop open
and
uh but it keeps this bishop locked and
you'll see how this bishop being locked
is often a big problem
in this opening
so it is why people choose to play c6
one of the drawbacks to c6 though is
that first of all it's not a central pun
and second of all it blocks this knight
so again this is the very basic level
right the basics and then we're going to
go deeper and deeper and deeper
obviously these guys know that stuff but
i would say that that's more important
to learn first rather than any kind of
deep flap i would say that before you
learn a line 10 moves deep learn it
three moves deep
so d5 and now there are many options you
can take
but this allows the knight in is one of
the main drawbacks but it also fixes the
structure which enables white to put
their pieces on good squares usually
they do either this
building this kind of solid setup i
would say these pawns work well against
this knight
and this is of course an option which is
normal or white can play like this
and often this leads to isolated pawn
play because eventually black takes this
pawn not usually right away
and then it leads to isolated pawn play
yeah you can do a london a london can
sometimes transpose but i'm not going to
get to that that's
a bit more than what i want to do
and of course white has options like
this well i can't even play a move like
f3
which of course has the drawback of
opening up the king a bit but it's also
going for
the severe panduo and you'll see
normally black either will play a move
like queen b6 try to put pressure on
this pawn
or they'll take and play e5 once again
trying to exploit the fact that
white's opened up their king
a little bit
but even things like this you have to
understand very well if you're choosing
to play the kero khan
uh and again it's all just pluses and
minuses i'm not really claiming one
opening is better than the other
uh three five against
which line against the the advanced
maybe
uh there's also this move and usually
that leads to a capture and then black
has different options they can play here
the drawback of this is they have to get
doubled pawns either with this or with
this but the advantage is that they
trade off this knight right away and
they tend to get good development in a
position like this you play bishop d6
castles you get pieces out
whereas this one it's creates more
awkwardness
you can play in a bd7 trying to get this
with
uh without wrecking your pawn structure
but this also blocks your bishop and
that can create problems for example
white can play this
and now a main move which looks very
strange is this
and one of the ideas is that it actually
exploits this knight because if you try
to kick the knight which looks very
strong i can play this move and you feel
horrible about your life
because if you take you get mated
and if the queen comes out with check
you simply block with tempo
and again i'm not going to include every
single line right i just want to show
you some of the basics so typically that
means black would have to play something
like e6
and bishop d6 and life kind of goes on
but the drawback again is you kind of
have to block your bishop
so again when i'm showing you all this
i'm showing you pluses and minuses i'm
not making claims as to which opening is
better
and then there's what most people play
which is this
and the point of this is to secure the
bishop outside the pawn chain uh not the
pawn chain in this case this very solid
structure
and the drawback of this though is it
does take a little time and it does
allow white to play have some aggressive
options one which is actually one of the
main courses of action is actually go
after the bishop right away
and you don't win the bishop but you
tend to get this structure
which sometimes in the long term this
pawn here is very annoying for black and
sometimes there are some weaknesses
but this is also quite solid and a whole
a whole other thing
so
this is just what the kerocon can look
like in this game though we see the
advance
so the advance what's you guys think
i'll start to ask you guys some
questions rather than just talk my head
off
what are some of the advantage what what
do you think is an advantage and a
disadvantage of playing this move
forward
we're getting the real basics here but i
think this is important
it's funny i see overextended in space
which actually means the same thing
you're gaining space in the center
but sometimes you that means you end up
overextended if you end up overextended
what that typically means
is that
you've pushed a little bit too much that
your pawn is a little bit too far you
you push your pawns a little too far
ahead and sometimes they become weak
so that's one advantage i would say
another disadvantage and this is the
thing people always forget
is that it does not develop a piece
and it's not a tempo move
one advantage this move for space is of
course a much worse move
but it gives white the move back meaning
that white is up a tempo or a half tempo
or a half move you could say compared to
this move because this passes the move
to black that's a very significant
downside
uh an upside as someone pointed out is
it does keep take the f6 square away
from the knight
which is a pretty big deal it makes it
harder to develop
and again this is all basic stuff but
you want to have a clear handle on it so
in this position the main move for black
is to play bishop f5 again the whole
idea of this is to get the bishop
outside the pawn chain and then you're a
tampa behind a french but you have a
bishop outside so what i mean by a
french
is
let's say this happens this is very
normal black can play this and they're
up a tempo because they have a pawn here
but their bishop can also not get to f5
and often the bishop on c8 ends up bad
again not making claims about whether
it's better or not that's for people
smarter than i am
but showing you how it works whereas
here if black wants to play this which
believe it or not is a move
they're a temple behind because they
don't have this but that also gives them
options so if white plays more passively
like if they play a move like this and
let's say we just do this and black goes
here
black's actually quite happy here
because they have a very nice structure
they're attacking d4 which is the weak
pawn in the center if white ends up over
extended that's probably the pawn that's
going to be weak
and the bishop is outside the pawn
chains you don't have to worry about
having a bad piece so even though black
lost time by doing this
they did well because white played more
passively so overall these positions
tend to be decent for black so typically
what white does is they actually break
apart their own pawns and normally this
isn't recommended all the time
but the advantage of this so black can
either go here trying to take this pawn
or play knight c6 first
and then either e6 or bishop g4 and
there's all sorts of theory but the main
point is that because
what blacks a tempo down white's trying
to open the game
so this is something i want you guys to
remember not these moves necessarily but
the concepts
if your opponent loses time
that's you're more likely to want to
open the game
but if you play slowly
and they get a bishop outside their pawn
chain it actually works in their favor
because their extra tempo allowed them
to get their bishop out
um
i think it's fine to play almost any
opening like it as long as it's sound
and relatively sound and you like it i i
don't want to say you can't play this or
you can play this i i just
there are certain openings that are much
more difficult to learn
but i don't know i grew up playing panov
and i think it's a fine choice you learn
about isolated pawn positions i think a
lot of people
are not comfortable playing with an
isolated pawn
and i would say that because i played
panov a lot i learned to be comfortable
with an isolated pawn
and you kind of take that with you and
it doesn't mean i seek isolate a pawn
everywhere it's just if i get an
isolated pawn i know how to play and
it's one of the important things
so bishop f5 is very direct so getting
the bishop outside the pawn chain
and i don't want to discuss these moves
like too much white has endless choices
here
they can play moves like knight f3 moves
like h4 moves like knight c3 and knight
d2 pretty much everything is possible
here
and it's very hard to explain each of
these moves one by one
the main thing though is you have
lines which aim to develop and then kind
of play c4 at some juncture
and you have lines which aim to expand
on the king side which also makes sense
because when you have a pawn chain
pointing this way that usually means you
want to play on the king side you play
where the pawn chain is pointing
so trying to play on the king side
ends up making a lot of sense so moves
like h4 look crazy
at first but when you realize that well
first of all it prevents e6 because
you're going to trap this bishop and e6
is a natural move
and it also expands on the side of the
board where white is going to have more
space it starts to make sense
and
trying to play trying to develop
in various ways is another thing i've
played for example i've used to play
this system and this system the main
purpose is black wants to get in this
move and the knight on b3 makes it a lot
harder to do seems simple
but sometimes ideas are just about that
i don't want to say which opening you
should play in which opening you
shouldn't again these are not i hate it
when people are very firm on this
because i think that we don't really
know what's objectively better and it
doesn't matter for most players
the most important thing is that you'll
understand not only what you're playing
but the purpose of what you're playing
if you play 92 to b3 understand you're
trying to aim against c5
in the game duboff plays what in my
opinion is the most intuitive he simply
develops so knight f3
e6
bishop e2 simply develops pieces
so you can play bishop d3 and try to
trade bishops but trading these bishops
doesn't really help white's position and
in general when you have extra space
keeping pieces on the board is kind of
nice
so g4 g4 is actually
playable as far as i know although it's
considered slightly dubious because
black can play here and that forces f3
and then the bishop goes back and f3 is
a little bit of a weakening move
so it's one of the disadvantages of
playing this way you can often end up
overextended
so knight f3 e6
and again some of this might be
disputable
as far as i know g4 is not considered
the best but it's still played by gm's
right so it's not that bad
but okay
so e6
bishop e2
and here black has various options so
the most direct is to play c5
immediately that's what black's shooting
for any kind of structure like this this
is a french structure whether you like
it or not you could be playing a caro
it's a french structure
but most importantly what that structure
means is that you have to play for the
break c5 or the break f6 at some point
playing for f6 especially down a tempo
remember if you're doing this your donna
tempo is very difficult
but it can happen but you have to crack
at the pawns in some way eventually if
you never crack at these pawns
eventually you're just gonna have no
room for your pieces and notice how
white has not traded anything
so this is not a very good thing for us
if this happens
so k-mer plays c5
but there are other options there's a
slower way of playing with knight d7
but the drawback of this is that if you
ever play c5 now this knight can't go to
c6
and sometimes that's a big disadvantage
so let's say white castles
so here there are various ways to play
one way to play is like this with the
aim of playing c5
and putting this knight on c6 which is
actually quite harmonious
but white does have a fairly annoying
move here
i'm curious if any of you either know it
or have seen it before
uh yes knight f3 bishop two i believe is
called the short variation but it's very
logical to me right you're just
developing your guys in castling i don't
see what can be more logical about that
pawn c5 if black play if white plays c3
i mean in general black wants to play c5
at some point if you don't play it ever
it's going to be bad so you probably do
so b4 is usually a bit too loose like
this pawn is just not very stable
so
even though you're stopping c5 you're
allowing ideas like a5 and then you have
to play c3 which is kind of ugly
um i can also just finish my development
and
to support this pawn eventually you're
gonna have to play a3 and this is just
too tempi that you can't spare
uh you don't wanna play b4 if all you
have to do is just like hold on to your
pawns for dear life
and of course eventually if black wants
they can try to play b6 c5 as well right
so b4 is the kind of move that usually
has more drawbacks than it has
advantages
so in these positions yes black usually
does want to play c5 and trade on d4
um
there's no backward pun um
but we'll get to this in a bit a move
like bishop g5 looks nice pinning the
knight but the problem is that after h6
this is the move i want to play anyway
and now you're going to have to move
your bishop again
so i would say that overall this is not
the kind of move you want either
very good lino knight h4 is actually
quite an annoying move here
the idea being that now because this
bishop is always attacked notice how the
queen no longer controls that square
because the bishop's always attacked
it's very hard to move this knight
so for example usually the bishop drops
back to g6 so that after takes you can
take with the h pawn if you need to
so white usually plays something like
knight d2 c5 c3
and the basic thing is white waits
and the second this knight leaves they
take and play knight f3 and this
position
looks like it's okay for black because
you have a decent structure this is a
very nice solid structure you've given
away
you you've given up the two bishops but
you've given up your worst bishop you're
a light square bishop
you haven't given up your dark squared
bishop
but the drawback to this is that
castling is never safe if you castle on
the king side you're you're walking into
h4 kind of attacks a piece of g5 h5
stuff like this
if you try to castle king side it's very
risky and you just don't have any active
plans so
i think at least when i was looking at
these positions i think these positions
are considered a bit better for white
black has ideas i'm not going to say
that black has nothing these are all
very playable positions and you might
like them but in my experience white ex
has a good good shot for advantage in
positions like this
because of that black's play evolved and
this is part of how opening play changes
preparation is not just
you know it wasn't just done overnight
right like it took years and years of
perfecting so one of the things that a
lot of people do now is rather than play
knight e7 they play the move h6 and this
is designed to combat net h4
so let's say white plays knight bd2
which is a typical useful move knight e7
knight b3 again discouraging this move
so because g5 is really hard to achieve
now
because then you're a bit behind a
development h6 is not a developing move
so black usually plays here
and this line gets really unclear but
this g5 move puts a little pressure on
this knight
and makes it so that black can maybe
play bishop g7 f6 maybe they can play
queen c7 castle's queen side and it
gives them different options so these
lines are very complex but this is a way
that black can play here
that combats this knight h4 idea
so that's knight d7 right
there's also a move which is kind of a
funny move which is knight e7
so the purpose of this move
is that
you're kind of staying flexible you can
play with knight d7 or you can play with
c5
so it's kind of a bit of a flexible move
and playing knight h4 in this position
makes a lot less sense um
i think the main reason
is that my knight's not stuck on d7 so i
think i can play like with c5 knight c6
right away
and if you take here and take this is
not anything that black worries about
and you have good pressure here
so i think because of that this is
actually kind of a clever way to play
so typically white castles
and now black can still play knight d7
of course and then at h4
but they play c5
and this is a kind of position where
it's very very complicated
but the key here is to understand what
the drawbacks
the advantages and disadvantages of
playing this way are
so if you were white here how would you
approach playing against this move c5
uh i wouldn't say that dead a lot like
sacrificing the style of like he would
often play
sacrifices for
i would say for more
you know he would not be sure they're
good but he thought it looked
interesting and he would play them there
are still people who play this way
maybe not as well as he did it but i
would say that it's harder to do that
now because people defend better now
especially at the highest level but i
think at all levels if you just
sacrifice willy-nilly people know how to
defend they don't get as
they don't get as
thrown off and part of it is because
computers defend so well but i would say
that that's part of it
so c4 is a very natural move one of the
drawbacks of c4 i've always
is that it does weaken this
d5 pawn so sometimes white will just go
c3 and just try to be solid but one very
common way to play which i think is very
decent is to try to crack with c4
and this is an approach to playing which
i think
sometimes amateurs in particular forget
about this which is that when you're up
in development meaning your castle your
opponent's not right black's nowhere
near castled
you do anything you can to open up the
board
and what black does
is they just want to keep things closed
and play here
so you have a kind of a funny situation
because
neither side really wants to relieve the
tension
if you take here and allow the night out
you've really helped black a lot because
now they're closer to developing if you
take here sometimes you allow a move
like d4 threatening d3 and then this
pawn is quite weak
so it's kind of like none of your
captures work so you gotta try to keep
tension so how do you improve your
position as white now
and this part is a little bit tricky
because
like how do you how do you justify this
you know
wow
so knight c3 is a possible move
but there's a big drawback to this which
is that if i play a move like a6
preventing knight b5 ideas
you don't really have an easy follow-up
i don't believe
like you can take this pawn but again
this helps me if you take this pawn i go
here and you have big problems
so you actually don't have a great
follow-up here playing a move like a4 is
very slow
any other move i can probably just start
like taking things and like i'm already
threatening to maybe take take and put a
knight here or something right
so it's actually white plays this move
and this is the kind of move where
explaining moves like this
to lower to students of mine say who are
not as advanced is so difficult because
it's like i i just stress don't put your
knights on the edge of the board
and now of course they're doing it
so devendra to answer your question if
you do play c3 as white your intention
typically is to take with a pawn that's
why you put the pawn there
so you're usually doing this to maintain
your space advantage even though it
gives you a weak d4 pawn whereas if you
take with a knight you're usually
playing for dynamics even though it
weakens your e5 pawn
and you're taking less space
so you're still your idea here is still
to play
knight b5 but the difference is that
after this
you can take here and it's a playable
move black can still play here and i
think blacks may be doing okay this
these lines are still quite unclear but
at least your knight's not getting hit
so
again if you're gonna put a knight on
the edge of the board it's fine but you
have to know why you're doing it if you
memorize the move it helps but you have
to have an understanding as to why
you're playing these moves
so
this is part of it and white has other
approaches though what i always kind of
liked was this move net a3
and this moves kind of funny because
you're still trying to do this
if here you take the pawn and you're not
committed to this which means that this
move is not really doing nearly as much
because it doesn't it's not a past pawn
anymore right
so typically they will go here
but now you play c4 and this pawn is
actually looser
so they can take and you go here and
this position is a complete mess of
course
really really complicated these
positions
but the idea is that this pawn is now a
lot looser and again if the center
breaks open before black's able to
complete the development they're
probably going to be in trouble
so when they play this way you really
want to try to play against that
and again there are different options
there you can pick and choose just make
sure you try to use these techniques but
the main technique of this whole system
for white is because you're developing
quickly you if they try to play a move
like c5 you can play with c3 there are
systems with c3 that are decent as well
but usually you want to try to open the
game before black has a chance to
complete their development that's kind
of your whole point of view
so
uh in this game k-mer plays c5 which is
i'd say the the main move quote-unquote
you could call it mohs testing if you
want again this is all debatable so i'm
not going to get into it
but here
once again understanding the position
fully is very important
because here what do you think white's
main move is again if you know the
system i'm sure you know the move but if
you don't like what would you say
white's move should be here
because i think that this move is
actually a very important one
and i'm sure you guys are going wait are
we ever going to approach dubai's
novelty and yes we will
but i would say that he didn't even have
really it wasn't even a huge novelty it
just was really good preparation and he
clearly had a better idea of the
position than k-mer did and that's what
happens
uh c4 is a possible move but you have to
keep in mind that
here i don't think it's quite as clear
because after c4 i can probably take
that guy and then my knight comes out to
c6 yeah and the problem is after knight
c6 like my bishop's not blocked taking
on c5 doesn't really do as much it
almost is better not to have this not on
e7 here so this is a playable move as
far as i know yeah i'm pretty sure this
is some line you play knight c3 knight
c6 and life kind of goes on
but i think black's considered to be
doing just okay here
so 92 here doesn't really cut it either
because i'm just gonna play knight c6
i've already gotten in the move c5
so putting the knight on b3 at least to
me makes less sense you can kind of play
this way and maybe you can just take
and play knight b3 or something but i
don't know i mean this doesn't look that
special my bishop's developed my knight
comes out next
and i don't really foresee too many
problems here for black either
so a move like knight d2 is probably not
what you're looking for
so this is it again right like
this is where if you remember your lines
you probably may know the move but
you want to understand why you're
playing this move let me ask you a
question first
uh yes simon bishop e3 is the move
uh so very good uh the main thing though
is why is castles not the move this is
the more interesting thing not saying
castles is a blunder by the way
not even saying it's not a legit move
but there is a very big drawback to
castling
here what is the main drawback to
castling
so c takes d is possible but after
knight takes d4 i think this is a good a
good
occurrence for white because the net on
d4 is good against the bishop here
probably that black will maybe play this
move and this is actually transposing to
a nine that's known
a little bit we'll probably get to it
later
but i would say taking is not such a big
deal
queen b6 does put the put a lot of
pressure on the center but i actually
would say that that's not such a big
deal either and in fact it might be a
risky move in some lines like there
might be lines where i try to break the
center open with c4 perhaps i could also
think about playing c3 and i feel like
it's actually kind of annoying for you
because it looks like you have this
pressure against the center but if i end
up taking and playing like
you can have issues with initiative here
i think so i don't know if i would
recommend queen b6 either
you have a much simpler move here for
black which i think is probably better
uh it's black's move
so yes bishop e3 is probably a bit more
accurate than castles in my opinion
but the question is why
knight c6 is extremely simple
and quite good
the main point is that of course it
takes bishop takes black's very happy
they're developed they have a good pawn
structure everything's nice
and if white plays bishop b3 now you're
a bit late so i can play something like
takes takes takes and now you don't get
a bishop you don't get a knight on d4
which is the best piece to have on d4
controls a lot of the center it hits
this bishop so it gains an extra tempo
eventually
so you have to take with a queen for
example and now you can play knight e7
to c6 get your bishop out
and white's really not gained enough in
my opinion i don't want to say this
isn't playable this is an option but
this is a very big drawback to playing
this way
so
white can of course play a move like c3
and c3 might be the best try for
advantage quote unquote whatever you
want to call it
but playing c3 means you're playing a
bit slower a bit you're allowing black
to finish development you're not playing
quite as aggressively
so it doesn't make it a bad move but i
would say that
black's opening has succeeded a little
bit because they have a very comfortable
setup here
the reason you play this move
is because now
first of all if they take this pawn you
play knight takes
knight e7 so this is actually a known
line so the bishop if the bishop moves
it's very very slow
and it does allow possibilities like c4
you know ripping open the center maybe
after castles and black can end up in
trouble because they're not very
developed so typically they play here to
get development
so taking a bishop like this unprovoked
is usually not great especially with a
bishop on e3 this bishop is now
misplaced and probably has to move
so you don't really want to take the
bishop
but once again i do think that
an accurate move is needed here for
white
well hello one and all
so what accurate move is needed for
white keep in mind black's next move is
going to be knight b5 most likely
c4 is possible
but i don't know that c4
actually i believe c4 is a move as well
yeah c4 is a move as well this is a
totally legit move something like knight
c6
queen a4 a6 preventing knight b5
and this is also a line so c4 is totally
legitimate but one way to play for white
which i was thinking was 92 and i just
want to illustrate that the whole idea
is that you get a knight here
so if black takes you take you still
have a knight that hits this bishop
which means this knight can't move
so yes at some point you can move your
bishop but it is slower and you have to
be very careful there's a bishop check
that's a threat so you probably have to
play with a6 and again it's not that
this is necessarily horrible but it's
very very slow and in fact most people
don't play that way most people will
play either bishop e4 here or bishop g4
and try to keep tension and
again
it's an unclear position but definitely
white has some decent chances here
so that's kind of the main point and if
you play knight c6 because i put my
bishop here i can just take that pawn
and sure it's not the only line black
has other options but in general this is
not such an easy pawn to get back for
example if you play queen a5 check i
play c3
you can't really take the pawn because
of b4
so bishop e3 combats knight c6
so c takes d of course is a very
playable line c takes d and knight e7
but the really sharp move which is what
k-mer played is queen b6
if someone plays queen b6 against you
confidently you probably know they know
this line
and this is again where
knowledge really comes into play if you
do not know this system this is where
you can have problems
so
i talked before about how you're a
certain level you don't really have to
know the opening as much as principles
that's totally true
the second you get to a level where
people can blitz out this theory against
you you got to know some stuff if you
want to play sharply you can play lines
which aren't as aggressive as white
and not have to know all sorts of crazy
stuff that's a totally legitimate option
most of your games will not be decided
in the opening anyway
but what i would say is that if you want
to play the sharp stuff there's nothing
wrong with that you got to know your
things so does anyone know what white's
uh correct move here is
knight c3 very good your pre your next
line is not correct but knight c3 is
indeed the move which looks crazy
because you're sacrificing this pun
but the idea
there are many ideas here and part of it
though
it makes logical sense black is not
developed black has one bishop out and a
queen and we know queens don't count for
development right
and white's one move from castling black
is at least three
so what that tells you is that playing
for aggressively playing sacrificially
makes sense here
so someone asked me about playing like
tal and all of this
i would say that
you can want to play aggressively you
can want to play solidly you can want to
play any way you want you have to do
what your position demands and i would
say that when you have a development
lead you should aim to play aggressively
that being said if you don't know what
you're doing here is what you can still
end up losing a bunch of pieces
so
in this case
um so for example let's just say you
play a move like b3
now a lot of people will cringe at a
move like this
and for good reason it's just it's not
only a potentially weakening move it's
also a waste of a tempo and for me
that's way worse
the fact that you're costing yourself a
move when black's played a very useful
move
is not good so now after something like
knight c6
i could even just take and play bishop
c5 and black's not going to have any
issues here they're going to get
developed castle this pawn is going to
be weak the b3 move is going to be
weakening probably too
this is exactly what white does not want
to do
now one option for white which is
actually quite interesting i find
is the move castles
and this is where
you can actually do prep that throws
people off horribly
knight c3 is what most people will know
probably a lot of people won't know the
move castles
and if you throw this at someone and
they don't know it you can actually get
a free win or a really huge advantage
so my first question to you guys let me
try to get you guys to do it
uh yeah 2am it's hard to calculate but
it's good practice so you learn to
calculate when you're tired
so my first question is should black
take the pawn on b2 or should they play
a move like knight c6
what do you guys think
4am oh my goodness so people if it's
past 3 am then you have good excuses not
to calculate if it's before 3am you
should still calculate a little
if it's uh three in the afternoon you
can fall asleep those are the general
rules
so knight c6 is kind of what i think a
lot of people would do like ah that pawn
looks dangerous i don't want to eat it
but the problem is if you play a move
like queen b6 and you're not willing to
take this pun sometimes that leads you
into trouble because it's kind of like
that's the whole point of your play
so after knight c6 i play c4
you're kind of in some trouble here and
this actually happened in a game between
manuel petrasyan not the world champion
or the other guy
and a 2400 player
which went takes
takes takes takes
black has to take this rook otherwise
they're just going to have an awful
position
queen b3 hitting this pawn castle's
queen side
knight c3
he has to sack the queen
and believe it or not black's already
toasted they have no development the
queen's kind of better than the two
rooks when the rooks can't get out
and black white has a huge attack so
black tried to grab some material but
after takes
knight b5 white got a huge attack again
pieces lying on the back rank not going
to do very well
so this is again how you can just win
games sometimes
so after c4 i think black's already in
some trouble
the best move is queen takes b2 in my
opinion
and now white still plays c4
and believe it or not i think black only
has one move
that keeps equality or keeps chances for
equality here
so best of luck to you black to play
only one move
none of you have it
one thing i'll say for you guys is if
you try to retreat as black you're in
big trouble because
then i'm just gonna just decimate your
center by taking d5 i'll bring my knight
out i mean you can't you can't just play
passively here you're behind in
development which means that if you just
let the center open for free you're
gonna have big trouble
but you are correct that you do have to
play a defensive move if you take this
and i play queen b3 you're in huge
trouble
threatening this
and here i play knight c3 and you have
to sack your queen again and once again
even though you get two rooks
i'm the one with development i'm the one
attacking everything every which way
you're in huge trouble here
completely losing in fact
so when i say that openings
for most players don't matter if you get
to a stage like this and white knows the
opening in black doesn't it matters a
lot
yeah none of you have found the move
which doesn't lose
or which doesn't get to a very bad
position let's say
i'll give you a hint ask yourself what
is white's biggest threat here
it's actually a very very simple threat
so bishop c2 i think just doesn't really
work
probably because i can just pin you
right
yeah this pin looks very nasty to me
bishop takes b1 helps me because now i
develop my rook and i'm still going to
take all your pieces not a good idea
bishop b7 king f8 would be quite
something but no i'll give you a hint my
threat is takes here
taking on c4 i think makes sense but the
problem with this move i believe is that
after i play something like this and
knight here you're just
like this is just too many tempi like i
think my i just have too much here i'm
not positive actually if this is the
correct move knight bd2 but it wouldn't
surprise me i might also be able to take
and i also have a lot of development
here i'm threatening these things
oh we have it simon very good 97
you have to defend this pawn
and you develop a piece so this really
really works out well
because if i take on d5 then you play
knight takes that's good for you so i
play here
knight c6
knight b3 this was all tried
takes bishop takes
rook d8 also necessary you don't want to
castle into this kind of attack
and here it's all sorts of craziness but
black's doing okay there are lots of
possibilities i don't want to get into
everything
but the main thing to take away is black
is doing okay but you have to know all
of this stuff
in order to play this so if you want to
surprise someone a move like castles
could be really really nice
uh in the game
knight c3 is played which is the main
move
and this move is also kind of
interesting so
uh black can try to close it up with a
move like c4
and this is actually kind of an
interesting way to play but the drawback
is with any kind of c4 move i can start
doing this to try to play for b3 and
this can be quite annoying
so for example queen d8
[Music]
castles you don't want to walk into
bishop before so usually black will do
this
and i think this kind of position can be
very very dangerous for black you kind
of turn into a weird french where your
bishop's out here
but the problem here is that
this bishop is actually not very good
because you have to defend your b-pawn
so people do something like this
and now you can play bishop g5 important
move and then net h4 and this bishop
just has all sorts of problems
if you go back i can even try to play f4
f5 on you
it's not going to be
all that fun
so this position i think is quite good
for whites
the carol is very sharp it's a very
interesting opening it truly is but you
have to really know what you're doing
queen takes b2 though you have to know
what to do against
and this is where knowledge really helps
so if you don't know this move is white
good luck finding it is the thing i
would say
it's one of those moves where without
knowledge it's quite difficult
i remember
there were lots of games where this has
occurred but one i remember very
distinctly was where um i think it was
larry christensen played this against
yasser sarah won in a u.s championship
yasser hadn't played in a lot of years
and i think entering this sharp stuff
especially against a player like larry
was a bit dangerous and i think he lost
really horribly here
so rook p1 i can take your knights and i
don't think you're doing a lot if bishop
here i can maybe take your pawn
it's a lot of pieces to give up
knight p5 is the old move so to speak
but believe it or not this move is
actually not so great because i can
pitch the exchange like this
so white usually will play here
uh something like this because if you
try to play like if you try to go for
this
i take bishop takes c2 and this position
is actually quite bad because i do this
this knight is going to be lost and i
have these two pawns for the exchange
which is way too much
so knight p5 is actually not such a
great move you can still go for this if
you play like this
and this position is actually not that
easy
uh i think one of the keys here is that
you have to put your bishop back on e8
and i'll show you what happens the one
of the main tries here is something like
bishop d2
knight out
h4 with idea of playing here
and believe it or not this position is
important black can take because knight
g5 i can simply retreat and this pawn is
defended
so you have to put the bishop on e8
it also helps because your knight has
the c6 square i'd say it's also
important i mentioned it because a lot
of people put the bishop on c6
but these are the kind of details you
need to pay attention to even in these
lines which aren't the best
like you got to know
your stuff
now would someone like vincent camera
know a lot of this probably i would
suspect he would
but most players especially who are not
gm's to know all this is is difficult
even for gm's to know all this is
difficult so you can surprise people a
lot but an mp5 is not considered the
best move these days
uh i always liked it davindra i like i
thought c5 is kind of interesting you
just have to be very careful because you
are behind that tempo right away
and i do believe that like white does
get some advantage there i think that's
what people who know more about the caro
khan than i do tell me
so
yeah king d2 not quite i think that's a
bit too loose i can play
takes in bishop before perhaps
i don't know a little bit too much
knight a4 also i can probably just take
this pun
believe it or not the correct move is
the move queen b1
and this move looks kind of crazy at
first but it makes sense when you
analyze it a bit if it takes the knight
bishop d2 you basically just lose
because you have to take this pawn most
likely and then i take this pawn and
this
rook is a goner and you're not developed
so you'll probably just lose your king
as well
so this move is not so great
queen before is actually a possibility
here i think white can actually just
play a3 and you still have the same
problem
i'm not totally positive about that but
i think queen b4 is a move here uh
what should your elo be i don't know i
mean you can learn the carol when you're
starting even it's just you have to
learn
don't try to play a line like this until
you're ready to tackle all these crazy
lines you know if you're not ready you
can play quieter versions and it's
totally fine
if you're a complete beginner i think
e45 is just good so you learn basic
concepts but once you pass that stage
you can kind of play whatever
so they go into this end game but this
end game is actually very difficult for
black
uh you kind of have to play c4 to block
this bishop rook takes b7
and the whole idea is that
white plays this and they just get huge
huge attack
rook c7 and even though it's an end game
uh this happened in the game
uh karjakin against alyanov it was a
famous game in 2010 that basically
refuted this whole line
so black gets this pun
but basically this pawn on d6 is a pain
and black's lack of development is just
too tough
so a position like this karjakin ended
up winning quite decisively here
so this is not really recommended to
take on b2 here
so
k-mer plays the main move knight c6
and now white castles
so here once again c4 is a move but then
there's rook b1 and again i kind of like
white but it's still unclear like these
lines are very messy
locked positions like this can be very
tricky to play
so
in this game
camera played queen takes b2 which is
the main move and once again
knowledge of the position is so crucial
so first of all queen b1 does not work
as well here does anyone have a guess
why
remember every little detail matters
you put the king back on e1 the knight
back on b8 queen b1 is a brilliant move
here it is actually a very bad move
because of one little difference
the rook's not trapped that's true but
if you do decide to take the knight and
i take here i still think your position
is quite bad i'm attacking two pieces
right
so what is the critical difference
he can move the rook but the key move is
that after takes takes black can play
castle's queen
side and this move solves all of black's
problems if you can't even take because
of d4 this position is actually just
lost for white most likely this is just
a free pawn
and it's all because black has to move
castles queenside
so this queen b1 move only works with
the
knight back on b8
knight b5 is a move but then c4 and we
encounter the same problems as in the
other line basically that taking this
rook is not good enough you win the c2
pawn and life is actually not so great
so white actually plays the move queen
e1 again this is all known both players
knew this
so again and you can go on and on each
move has very specific reasons for it
and before the players could ever hope
to try to prepare some novelty on move
15 or 20 you have to understand how all
this works
so
i'm showing you more
the layers and understanding and opening
and getting it to gm level before or you
know any kind of high level right before
you
you know proceed with going down even
further
so
takes d4 was played
again one of the main lines
another really important detail knight
takes d4 is typically a poor move
because after bishop before
knight here takes
you have to take with the knight and
then d4 is a fork
so you play bishop takes d4 and the
whole point now is that after knight
bdb5
rook b1 is another line i'm actually not
going to get into it i want to make sure
i get the game
knight db5
and the whole point here is that now if
you try to go for this d4 does not win
anything
so black just is in a situation where
they're behind a lot of tempe
so bishop e5 check's annoying so usually
they play here rook b1
queen a3 and here there are different
options again another karjakin game
where he won quite decisively
it wasn't as perfectly played as the
other game against alyanov but the basic
gist was that after this he has this
really cool sacrifice bishop b5 check
and if takes knight takes is just way
too much uh play and you basically just
kind of get slaughtered your king gets
slaughtered
so he had to play here and then bishop
back to d3
and with the king on f8 black did not
fare very well this game again not
perfectly played but
that's the general idea
so
this is again all known so because rp1
is a threat black has to step out of
that and knight c7 is also in the air so
the move bishop a5 comes to mind it
takes away control of the d6 square
but it does control c7
so once again there's there are
different moves but dubois chooses rook
b1
um i haven't analyzed too many openings
on this channel i have videos out there
you search my name you can find quite a
few things
i tend not to be as opening focused but
i have done quite a few opening videos
even recently so
um yeah so there's actually a line
a lot of games actually are drawn with
this move and this is a very funny one
after here takes knight takes the bishop
goes here knight back
you pin the knight again here
a lot of games draw this way but dubove
is a fighting player he plays rook c1
couldn't be two net a4 and this is again
all been played before
but the whole point is that
if you don't play knight a4 your pieces
are just completely tied so you do this
the queen exchange is forced because
you're threatening queen takes bishop so
you have to exchange queens
if knight c7 is a threat you must play
bishop a5
so keep in mind move 16 both guys still
are in theory both guys still know what
they're doing and a lot of it's because
they've studied a ton but a lot of these
moves are actually relatively forced
so white plays knight d6 check so notice
how black's up two pawns but because
white has a much a big lead in
development black has to be very careful
so the king goes to e7 white nabs one of
the two pawns
so this is another detail which i
believe k-mer gets correct so there are
two moves here bishop here and bishop
here you have to really stop rook be c7
check or you're in trouble
the move bishop e6 looks more logical
and of course would probably be played
first
but white has to move knight a4
and this move is a very big problem
because
if knight takes bishop here you're in
trouble you can't really go back now
because knight a4 is such a nice
improving move you don't really want to
give that for free
so a move like bishop d4 would be
logical
but now you can play this and the idea
is that
black believe it or not black should
probably sack this piece
but sacrificing a piece of course is
very difficult because if they go back
rook c7 check
knight bc5 and they're just under a
brutal brutal assault notice how you
can't take this because i
have a fork
and this position is already very bad
for black because their king is just in
huge danger
and they also don't have very many moves
but again this is really difficult stuff
to know to figure out over the board so
this is where if you don't have
knowledge like you're like well i know a
move an opening 18 moves deep how could
that not be enough if you're playing a
force line you have to know it as far as
it goes
so bishop d8 is correct
and the idea is that you don't give this
tempo for free so a move like net a4 now
is less effective
because it doesn't threaten anything you
can just play a move as black so you
take
once again you don't want the rook
coming to c7 so black takes with the
king this also allows the knight to come
out so black's up one pawn but they
still have some development to catch up
on
rook fd1
and this is where
things
you know are not so simple
i would say that the main thing that
white's trying to do is activate the
knight with knight c4 that's one of the
purposes of putting the rook on d1
otherwise you're there's no reason to
attack a pawn that's defended so well on
d5 his main purpose is to be able to
play knight c4
uh g4 just restricts restricts the
pieces so black can't play g5 to get the
king out that's actually an important
detail in a lot of positions you want to
throw this in so that pawn can't get out
here when the king can get out this way
kind of an important detail
um
so
uh if you play king f8 earlier then
there are other problems because if you
put your bishop on d8 i can take it and
play rook c7 i think so you want to be
able to take it with a king
this is all very complicated guys
uh it's hard to explain with everything
you can play king e7 here but that
allows the check so you don't really
have the problem k-mer has is it's hard
to develop i think knight e7 would be
the most logical for me knight c4
and here i think that he really has to
try getting his rook on aja out so i'll
move like this
and here
there are lots of possibilities believe
it or not i actually think h4 might be
best
i think computer recommends this and
probably this is what dubai had in mind
or something similar
threatening g4 and the idea is that
if black plays black actually has to go
here
because in this position if they play h5
for example you can simply play knight
d6 and you're threatening this check and
this pawn is actually very bad you're
threatening just to take and take on f7
you can move away you just have way too
many options
so you can't afford a slow move against
this
if a move like f6 you can play g4 and h5
and the bishop has to go to an awful
square somewhere
also not good
so
you play this move
to get the rook out
and bishop b1
i just wanted to show this because of
how hilarious it is that this is kind of
what you have to do here
so the idea of course is that if you
take this bishop
you take the knight and black's doing
okay
so you play knight d6 bishop takes a2
bishop b5 check
black can't go back because of mate
so you have to sack the exchange
and this position i thought black had
some chances but maybe white's a bit
better
so just to give you an idea of like what
can exist in these lines like this is
the kind of stuff that these guys
prepare
most players not so much and most of you
do not have to do that but that's the
kind of thing that he probably prepared
here in the game camera played rook b8
knight c4 and almost kind of just fell
apart he probably still has to play
knight e7 here
knight d6 something like this
he played the move g5
but the problem is it's just very slow
knight d6 bishop g6 rook d4
97
so here probably
uh dubov could have already done
something like this and it looks very
good he chose g4 just to keep pressure
on and keep the knight out of f5 i
suppose
and yeah and this position it got really
crazy i think that
kmer had a chance because of the slower
move
but he had to find this move king d7
no doubt he didn't like it because
bishop b5 check again but he has to sack
the exchange
knight c6
and after rook a4
rook b8 allows the move rook a6 but he
can play a5 and because this pawn's very
weak because this rook is coming out to
b8 i actually think that maybe there are
some chances
but again to find this over the board is
where it comes down to so
their prep didn't necessarily come out
to just the objective value of the
position but here's what it came down to
do both knew it better than k-mer
probably because k-mer this is mostly
all he like a lot of what he plays so he
knows it well but the problem is that
dubov could be up all night studying
this and kmer doesn't know what duba is
going to play right duba plays
everything
and because of that
he probably didn't study this as
recently and he probably didn't know
dubai's exact move order or moves so
because of that
dubai had this fresher in his head and
even though he maybe didn't like okay no
one plays perfectly
i would say that
it just makes life really difficult when
you're the one under the gun in a sharp
position under pressure
and even someone as strong as kmer who's
again a very very strong gm
had some trouble
so he played the movie rook b6 and
already he's basically dead
white plays b5
so you're too late to sack the exchange
now your king needs to be on d7 so you
can shut off the rook
if you try to do this now i simply check
you and you feel silly
so he actually played rook back to b8
which surely wasn't his idea but after a
move like a6 white can play rook a4
threatening this and this is already
over
so the the fresh part of the game i
saved very little time for because there
really wasn't much
um
yeah and here it's just basically pretty
dead
so he played rook b8 but rook a4 knight
c8 and duboff does find a nice way to
kind of finish the game if you guys want
to try to solve that again if you've
seen the game you probably know but
white is a very very nice way
to seal the game
uh that is an idea chess luck but black
also needs time to get this and because
the knights on e7 and has to move he
just was not given any time
but it's why speed's so imperative keep
in mind he played rook b6 which
obviously was a blunder so if he has to
play rook back to b8
that's not going to be very good
that's just too slow but yeah if in some
lines he should definitely try to get on
so yes taking this knight is definitely
very tempting
but how would you like to do it
so sack the exchange
and yeah if you take this rook and take
here i play king b8 i believe and it's
not so clear the rook comes out and this
pawn is actually quite decent at some
point
but dubov has no intention of giving
away this beautiful knight he takes on
a7 hits d7
so rook d7 mate has to be stopped you
can throw in the check but it does
nothing he played here
dubois checked and took so he's
threatening mates he plays f6
and then one nice little finesse
oftentimes games like this can carry on
if the position remains complicated
but dubois found a very nice win at the
game he played rook c8 so the main idea
of this is that trading rooks is just
kind of bad
for black you can do this and then maybe
a move like this to make sure your
knight gets back to take this pun with
this fork
is a nice way to conclude it
so rook a7 and now rook c6 and now
camera resigned because knight c8 check
is a very big threat forking the two
pieces
and if the rook tries to take the pawn
for example you can check
take this pawn and this is definitely
over
so rook c6 is a very very nice way to
finish the game
so once again basically
this does not happen in most games this
is an exception but because zubav
prepared well knew the position well had
that kind of understanding we talked
about he was able to get a position
where kamer even a very well prepared
opponent he knew that bishop d8 move
remember i moved 16 or 17. he was very
well prepared but if you know it just a
bit better sometimes you at least put
your opponent in a difficult situation
so even a player this strong
can falter and as you saw duboff barely
had to play any moves himself
he basically had a pretty good idea
he knew what was going on in the
position vaguely and then
you know
kamer definitely could have done better
and i think a lot of opponents maybe
would have at least
not blundered right away but because he
had a such a difficult
task
he did blunder and ended up losing
and duba barely had to work for this for
this win
so
um
anyway i hope that
this uh this lecture kind of gave you
guys an idea of
what really top-level opening
preparation looks like i'm not
pretending to be on the level of these
guys but i'm at least trying to explain
it
and
also like how you can approach
preparation in your own games like not
just
knowing it to move 10 or 15 but knowing
the first several moves what they do
what their purpose is
like what the nuances are what the
differences between each kind of idea is
and the better you understand that kind
of stuff the better it will serve you as
you play
uh so
this is actually my last lecture with
you guys i've been the gm in residence
for three weeks and it's time for me to
head off
but it's been a lot of fun doing these
and for sure i will be back so you will
see
you will see plenty of my lectures in
the future whether you like to or not
but thanks for joining me everyone i
hope you enjoyed it and i will see you
another time
[Music]
you